two one
are we live all right reject Nation it's
the time you know what to do tell us
tell us in the chat to tat tat tell us
if we're live tell us if you can hear us
leave a like
Andrew wasn't in the thumbnail but he's
here actually with his pervert mustache
if you could leave the stream actually
go watch the secret Invasion trailer
reaction and then come back to the
stream share it share it yeah yeah we're
uh we got messed us up and it was crazy
the first like 10 minutes they had like
10K views and then it got blocked and I
was like great now it's gonna get messed
up in the algorithm
so yeah d23 sucks just because because
of whoever that claimant was that set
that little thing up in the algorithm to
claim people our days of Shilling for
Marvel or over yeah no more chilling now
we're gonna go hardcore and praise
zoslov we're free David here so all
movies Andrew's never been live with us
Andrew first time for everything well as
long as uh Disney and Marvel keep giving
sending me my checks I'm Gonna Keep
chilling for them dude I like your
checks they are really nice and big
what are you doing John just letting
Aaron know that he's good Aaron
Alexander he's representing us hey guys
okay what's going on here Andrew so this
is your first time being live with us
let's shout out some people who are in
the chat we got
spike91919100 huh is that exciting shout
out to someone Andrew what a gem Mr Duff
it's very good that's very good we got
Adam H in here we got the nerdy wave why
don't you still left a tiny bit it is
very good at your framework
um and then we got Joshua
oh my God yeah I saw campia going
railing into the d20th you told me about
it it can't be he's trailing so pissed
off he can't be it was so mad John
my friend calm down there's no need to
be that upset about it
unless it gets more people into your
live stream then yeah be as upset as you
want to be
um I'm I guess I would say this is I
find it ironic well I was gonna kick
this off hi Asia Renee
um Glenn Moore Corey I I think what I
find uh slightly uh disappointing about
it
because I'm not exactly disappointed
if anything I was I'm more surprised by
how it was the opposite effect
of John what's going on there so done
Jesus
take the phone away Mr distracted that's
always that's that's me here's what
here's where I'm a little let down by I
will have uh I will be on is it the
Fantastic Four announcement or Henry no
I think it's hilarious they did not
announce the Fantastic honestly that's
so funny because that's pretty funny so
many people doing videos this week about
a fantastic forecasting coming out and
the fact there was no lacaste lineup I
for some reason was like I don't know
it's kind of funny to me because it's
going to come like we know for sure it's
not a question like with is Toby in it
or not it's not that it's like yeah
there's going to be a cast filled for
sure eventually like there's no there's
no question about it it's just there's
gonna be no cash it's just funny that we
go see the movie there's nobody at all
wire models showing up instead of the
Cavs I just think it's so funny because
people were just really right in that
way so much this weekend and nothing
came out
I'm at the point where I just not
believing anything until I see smart
call you're a smart man Drew but anyway
no what I was um what I was thinking
about is uh
it's like so many of us like I
especially thought this well it's koi's
at d23 actually there go follow him on
Tick Tock for 15 seconds 30 seconds one
minute I'm the poor man's koi guys okay
when koi is not available then they call
me that's how it works around here yeah
poor koi or we're called Eric but he's
at 2023. did Aaron McCoy are both out of
commission hey man you betrayed me and
started going on jabby co-way's Channel
all the time yeah this this is a blood
Feud that you cannot you do not know the
extent of what you have done yeah which
Predators I need to finish my thought do
it please finish that [ __ ] my thought is
this is that a lot of us thought that
Comic-Con would be light and d23 would
be insane
and then Comic-Con ended up being not
disappointing at all with especially
revealing the Avengers titles and stuff
and then having the tease for all the
blank slates in phase six
and the d23 was like oh
it's just like I'm sure it was great for
everyone who was actually at the event
you know oh it looked like it would be
so much fun in that room yeah and they
got they gotta actually you know they
got to see stuff that we didn't get to
see they got to see the Black Panther
footage which I heard was great
right guys I heard it was it it told us
well I'm sure I'll teach you how to live
stream okay while we're live teach me
how to live teach me in the moment
Ricardo Thomas Manuel Hernandez you
are a brave person okay Alex please go
check out campus stream as he rails into
d23 today oh man he's gonna I hope he's
okay we should call and make sure he's
not you know suffering
yeah that was my my whole thinking of it
like I'm sure if you were there inside
the room it was beyond a blast but I
mean with the the stuff we got like the
uh the werewolf by Nitro like that was
amazing the secret Invasion stuff that
was great I mean look was it
disappointing I mean it's all a matter
of perspective it just depends on how
you know how hype your expectations were
and I've just at this point I've learned
like hey I'm not going to believe
anything until I actually see it so I'm
just not going to Hype myself up we're
all I mean we know we're gonna get all
this stuff like in the moment it's
totally understandable for anyone who
did feel disappointed like I can totally
sympathize with you I don't feel like
you're an entitled baby or anything but
I totally get it uh you know you you had
you had expectations and they weren't
met or filled so it would have been cool
if they would have revealed all this
stuff and given us the footage that they
gave the people in there but you know
what look in due time we're gonna get
all this stuff we're gonna get
everything we want so I just look at it
that way and yeah I'm curious I'm
curious as to what Fawn uh like Fosters
these conversations because like I'm
trying to like looking at this and
looking at the past couple it's like
when Marvel and DC don't show up to a
Comic-Con or when they only bring like
one thing I feel like that's you know
sure disappointing uh and here you know
in the in the time of leaks and so many
rumors and sources and and things like
that I feel like they still put out and
and announced a fair amount of things
it's just like because so many of us are
so ravenous it's like okay well half the
stuff we already knew so I'm like what
is the the the actual threshold of
disappointment I guess what and what
would have been satisfying that's what I
want to know comment comment what would
have made if you feel disappointed what
would have made today satisfying for you
well you know if you talk to Les
and actually read what everyone's been
saying you would have already had that
answer
because while you were talking
I was listening to the people in the
chat
so I'm gonna find the exact ride balance
between reading only reading but also
talking so it's funny hearing some of
you guys go back and forth in this chat
I'm not going to name anyone super
specific right now but I see it if you
have a big big screen that's showing us
your old chat right now and it's some
people are like I don't know why you'd
be disappointed by the fact that you're
did not get announcements of things you
won't see for like year of months to a
few years from now right or some of that
and the other people the other flip side
is the fact that there was all this hype
leading into d23 Kevin feige himself
kind of hyped it up pretty much so that
would be I forget what he said exactly
but that it would be kind of a bit of a
like a mind-blowing event he said you
were gonna like you know have a big
orgasm in your bedroom when you heard
everything that was coming out but
apparently no for the most part A lot of
it is like a little bit expansions and
you know with Comic-Con they show us
everything versus
um or they don't show us everything but
they show us they showed us quite a
actually no the Ant-Man trailer only
played at Comic Con right and the secret
Invasion trailer there were things that
played a Comic-Con that did not play for
us at home correct yeah oh yeah and I
feel like at home it doesn't feel like
too many new things were shown to us
other than the secret Invasion trailer
which I thought was great and that
honestly if you watch everyone's seen a
werewolf By Night reaction I had no clue
what we were walking into stylistically
I had no clue I saw the thumbnail wasn't
black and white and I was like okay
probably just black and white show cool
and I was so surprised by what we had
and that out of everything that happened
today that was the most surprising thing
to me was the werewolf by night and the
fact that Michael jokino is directing it
and we know that he does you know film
scores and TV scores and all that but
that he's actually directing it and he's
so inspired from you know the movie
Monsters of the 30s the 40s and the 50s
and all that so I was really interested
that that was the choice they had so I'm
really curious to see what he's gonna do
with that because I mean I love his
music so much but obviously I've never
seen him direct but well yeah I mean we
had the John now you're just reading too
much not listening to the conversation I
am listening to the both of you are you
sure yeah
I hope so John yeah dude Andrew I think
up the the different stylistic
flourishes of a werewolf By Night
Michael Jackson either trying to prove
yourself it's okay I used to say
gianchino too all right so
I think I think the thing that happened
was the one expectation that happened in
my brain at least because Henry Cavill I
will I I can gladly say I did not
contribute we did not contribute to
anything to over hyping d23 for people
this we did not we did successfully and
I'm kind of proud of that so they're
overwhelmed so but the thing that I did
expect
um we got to stop the stream the
National Treasure trailer has dropped oh
no it's okay
um what the one thing that I did expect
was to have some of Asics revealed yes
even if it was like one or two titles
yeah for sure because feige did a whole
thing with like here's up phase five at
Comic-Con and then oh at the very end of
phase six look at that [ __ ] we have
Avengers and he and it's like he shows
you this blank ass slave blank ass he
shows you his blank white ass the [ __ ]
ass which also wears a cap and idiocracy
is in the same universe let's ask the
movie and then uh I thought also two we
were gonna get maybe a World War Hulk
trans man we're gonna get uh maybe Nova
Wonder Man but again I'm not
disappointed by these would I have loved
to have seen them of course I mean but I
think all in due time we're gonna get
these things but no exactly yeah yeah I
mean it's real up and down relationship
with Marvel I think with Marvel the main
thing they have going for them is that
people love to anticipate what they have
coming versus celebrating what they have
currently yeah that's probably the issue
but let's shout out some of the people
with the super chats right now I thought
we would get the Avatar 2 trouble let's
just see who's in the Super chats right
now we don't have a time I want to see
the Avatar three trailer first I would
love to see the Avatar 3 trailer and
Avatar four before I even like this
[ __ ] trailer ruin all of Avatar too
from here
all right Daniel Villanova thank you for
the contribution today where's Daddy Coy
he is at d23 we got invited to d23 but
we we thought like okay we're knowing
how d23 is we usually do better if we're
just here covering events so we didn't
go to d23 now I'm like maybe we should
have gone d23.
we could have come out of the room and
been like hey guys this is happening and
then broken news couldn't have reacted
to the secret Invasion trailer could not
have I got blocked for three and a half
hours or the werewolf By Night trailer
yeah
um but trade info when I'm hung out with
Andrew yeah exactly I mean why would you
go to d23 when you can hang out with it
now that is the true what did you guys
think about the Thunderbolts lineup they
want to know we will get there wow and
that's true Andrew is this your first
live stream let me teach you a rules too
about live streaming all right is this
something jabby's not gonna teach you
once we open the super chats because we
only got a few right now as usual we're
like let's wait till we got a plethora
but I'm like no we only got a few so
let's just read a few of these get
through them because they contributed
for their hard-earned dollars I was
reading a contributed one okay but we
have a list right here and we will go in
the order of which people contributed to
be fair maybe I need to drink some of
this look if you want to be coy you're
gonna have to learn how koi does which
is
that ship has sailed that will never be
as good as koi no one ever will be
that's the problem no no you're you're
you're you're better don't tell Corey
that don't worry this isn't recorded
Ricardo martini thank you Ricardo you
sweet sexy son of a [ __ ] you have a
great great name we love shouting you
out yeah we love shouting you out on our
patreon for whichever video that's on
Jacob C Andrew why don't you read that
comment that that first super here's the
goal with super chess you think them and
then you read their comment with
enthusiasm okay Jacob C Kevin hyped up
d23 in last year and kept and Comic-Con
set the bar High I think that they
definitely teased us with big
announcements and didn't deliver I'm
right fair enough that's what happened
well thank you Jacob see I mean Andrew
now what would you say to Jacob about
how would you console Jacob I mean I
didn't at Jacob how are you uh I didn't
hear Kevin feige's uh comments I would
just say hey look Kevin feige gave us
the MCU so I can understand your
disappointment if he really did
give you expectations like that and
you're a little disappointed with you
know what happened for sure I get that
but you know he's given us the MCU and
given us so many great films so I would
say Have a Little Faith we're gonna get
what we want and have faith in feige
have faith in the [ __ ] the fight you who
gave us Thor love and thunder the best
MCU film what are you talking about that
film is a perfect blend of balance
how can I be the only person who likes
that all right but I like the last half
a lot all right Bucky Barnes are our
faithful moderator moderator do
what up what's man appreciate you what
up to you what is up with you he's a
nice guy Joe you're a great guy Joe did
you Twitter at a live stream dude tweet
it out you're a [ __ ] job show Joe
what are we paying you for why don't we
pay you nothing Joe if you're not gonna
do anything huh somebody just wrote a
comment in the chat about their [ __ ]
being on fire and then retracted it I'm
like why oh it's on I told you guys
before the stream don't read negative
comments but I saw one about me and I
have to read it excuse me where is it
Greg still hyped he appears in always
sunny
isn't that bad though is that a bad
comment that's good I thought it was
going to say Greg still hyped something
I was ready to defend myself and I was
like I didn't have [ __ ] this week I
still haven't gotten yourself I did not
I really did think Fantastic Four was
for sure there wasn't a question in my
mind about it I for sure thought
Fantastic Four would be revealed today
but at least we got the director that we
already knew about yeah
I know
so many enough that was uh thanks Capra
that's a really sweet thing for you to
say
um I haven't seen the difference in
views through Mandalore entails Jedi but
yeah I mean it's funny yeah it's because
that's the thing is what em blush is
saying in the chat right now is that you
know I said lower your expectations for
Comic-Con which I don't think is ever
bad to do is lower reaction I don't
think it's ever a bad idea and and then
they end up like then I ended up being
like you know what they delivered
and I'm really like I I really thought
they would go all out with this one what
was that quote from MJ and Spider-Man no
way home about expectation or guys
listen on the chat it's been a while
since I watched no way expectation don't
expect anything or some [ __ ] like that I
forget it people quoted all the time in
her live streams actually guys help us
out what's that quote
um but yeah I think um I think uh that
the d23 was a bit of uh
I don't know I didn't
I guess because I wasn't really reading
too much into it I was just kind of
waiting to see what they gave us that I
was like Oh I thought there'd be more I
was just kind of like my reaction is I
thought there'd be more but I was I
wasn't like man I'm really
I'm really disappointed brother
by the event I I didn't walk away with
that but I I did think there would be a
little bit more I thought there'd be
something like truly new well yeah in
Comic-Con this year see from from my
experience of these of these conventions
and things what is it what's the line
what's the line expect disappointment
and you'll never be thank you Anna Laura
that's really really kind of you to look
out for us like that thank you when
we're just reading the regular chat
sorry Andrew I need to teach John a
lesson about live streaming really fast
we're just reading the regular chat
maybe let me take let me pull up the
notepad here so I shouldn't just keep
myself super chats pulled up because we
have super chats and we will get to you
guys in a second now we know that quote
from Spider-Man no way home was not
really for the movie was for us for d23
and for Comic-Con that's really what
it's before [ __ ] Colin Davis I'm curious
okay what happened when I don't know how
the crowd reacted to Taskmaster versus
everyone else on the test coin Aaron
yeah we could guys you just call them
yeah live react actually let me just
Text Aaron right now and just be like
hey how do people react when Taskmaster
was revealed everyone's favorite
character and the crowd real life
[ __ ]
[ __ ] hey man as long as they go back
and they give Taskmaster her actual
skills in in this case and uh and you
know maybe uh
I don't know just just give that
character some autonomy I think it could
be good I mean what do you guys okay
wait let's go back to the super chest
and someone did ask about Thunderbolts
in the in the in the contribution paid
paid version
that dude Jake C all right good you see
part of the rule of live stream that
we've learned over time with experience
Andrew
is that sometimes you start to answer
something and then you're like oh crap
we should Reserve that for a Super Chat
yeah even though they might be like you
know repetitive but it's a good thing
you caught anyway sorry I
I'm sorry it's okay I'm sorry it's okay
Aaron Hall that's not what I'm doing
I know how to do that though I can do
that
can't be a starter stream is he yelling
yet we should react to it is he pointing
his finger
what ridiculous
I feel like oh I'm shocked I feel like
you should go on his show doing an
impression of the difference though with
people who give Camp here crap is I I
make fun of Gambia but I really like him
I like the difference I understand it
can be a bit of a controversial figure I
would gladly say that the next time I'm
ever on John's show like I know you
could be a bit of a controversial figure
but I actually enjoy like talking with
you and you're you're fun and your show
is fun so yeah despite you know whatever
fun guy yeah fun guy John camping unless
of course this gets me in a lot of
trouble then you know what um
anyway that dude Jake C
all right Andrew what did we learn that
dude Jake C Thunderbolts lineup is you
forgot to thank him that's a John move
you got to thank him thank you Dad dude
Big C
Thunderbolts lineup is interesting weird
there was no Zemo agreed expected
Abomination as well but hopefully
Taskmaster has done better thoughts
it would be a chance to redeem
Taskmaster to make Taskmaster cooler I
think are you saying Taskmaster wasn't
cool in Black Widow that's exactly
yeah they did was the first thing we
talked about it yeah
um you got to show that comment don't
let that be yeah
um yeah I've really felt like uh
She-Hulk especially was heavily setting
up abomination even though where we're
at we've only seen it to episode four
like everyone else with She-Hulk and
then they had a preview with the
meditation camp that he has so I was
like okay is this all just like a big
mislead that he's gonna like Snap right
he's gonna snap we just gotta wait is
She-Hulk just going down the path where
abomination's gonna be
is going to be some kind of benevolent
figure moving ahead in small doses right
um and I thought I thought I think all
of us were expecting Baron Zemo to be in
there I really thought that was the
first thing we said too when we saw the
lineup were like no Zemo Zemo what if
what if if they have Hulk go out onto
some kind of World War hulk-esque uh you
know solo Quest what if they put
Abomination into the Avengers
oh that would be weird that would be
weird but I mean if Emile Blonsky in
this universe has reformed and become
kind of a lovable character I can see
weirder things have happened true true
more embracing the fact that this is an
alternate universe and do you think this
Taskmaster is going to be the Taskmaster
we saw from black widow or is it going
to be a Multiverse it's going to be a
dude with a big penis
the costume is going to be made of
original comments yeah and it's going to
say no boobs here I have actually been
seeing some people say that that could
happen possibly maybe Tony Masters this
is how you write conom in because it's a
Multiverse one possibly but yeah man
dude I totally get it yeah no for sure
hey if you guys are here can you leave a
like I'm about to tweet this stream out
I totally forgot to do that like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] like a total John
um John why don't you read this one
Joshua Langston the lack of Deadpool
John thank you Joshua Langston thank you
Andrew
thank you after the question sure that's
what great save am I right Andrew
part of this Joshua links to like team
up with it thank you Joshua Joshua
Langston I can't think you know what in
fact I can't thank you enough to the
point where I don't think we'll have
time for the question
which is the lack of Deadpool 3 News
depressed me it's not even a question
see that's what I love about you Joshua
Langston you say what you mean and you
don't even need our thoughts on it see
uh I'm not just chilling my phone
between the stream out yeah I I really
um
some Deadpool presence even like I don't
even expect them to announce the movie
yet especially for all the times they're
like yeah yeah we're still working on
the description right right and uh and
uh they got uh you know Reece and
wernick back so uh you know now they got
like four writers in this group so yeah
I'd expect some kind of Deadpool
presence and I'm surprised that for like
a d23 convention there wasn't some
cheeky sure I thought there would be
like at least Ryan Reynolds for a brief
appearance that's what I thought I was
just a casing to just come onto the
stage in case the great we will not
leave John alone no see that's what
problems in this chat it's not the real
but it's fun
you can't do that because that's exactly
what makes the it all increase
every any substitute teacher knows you
can't walk up to the other kids and be
like stop picking on that guy why is
someone asking about She-Hulk toxicity
in the chat that's a weird thing that's
a weird thing we'll get back to you in a
second to the chat we'll put a pin in
that Miss otter movies
I thought
wait oh I made my mistake
thank you for contributing how does it
feel
is like a goddamn embarrassment you suck
I thought the 23 was a nice companion to
Esther Cece Comic-Con was big titty
announcements yep and d23 had more story
in cast analysis yeah no disappointment
on my end well this is a neat way to
look at that that's actually I like your
perspective that's a really positive way
to spin it because yeah we got to hear
more about Black Panther 2 which is I
heard that name or is a badass and more
badass and everybody wants the resources
of what kind they want that of a
vibranium yeah and there's a sick battle
between embaku and Neymar yeah it's a
real toss-up now between who becomes the
Black Panther it's like embaku or or
Neymar vacuum or Siri right
um yeah I heard details about that I
heard that like there's a tiny bit more
with the Ant-Man footage yes
honestly the Mandalorian trailer which I
heard leaked a while ago I thought it
was
so
so beautiful yeah you said it best it's
one of the best Star Wars trailers I've
ever seen it really is one of the best
Star Wars trailers
it had better be uh yeah is there any
more in this current fresh that we have
right now surely
thank you Trey thank you Trey what's up
Trey sup to you Trey Trey you're a good
man Trey Skyward sages thank you thank
you for the moment of silence
is there a way to pull up like the the
uh regular chat
whenever oh my God Lana's here yo dude
Lana's a real sweet person
has been come popular live streams for a
very long time she's really sweet human
being
we will reach your super chat in a
second thank you Anna
um yeah what if Hulk is villain and
Thunderbolts is this setup for World War
Hulk I love that comment David Hutchins
that would be such a reveal I really
wanted to see Hulk Go full villain that
would be really neat I really like what
you're saying there full metal Hulk they
announced it was shuri
I have just want to go live and react to
John campus
I mean we could drop him in into this
stream it would be so funny right that's
what our stream is we're literally just
live streaming John campus it's so funny
this computer could probably handle it
he's a smart guy he knows what he's
doing he's really going into like what
he's pissed off about it's really really
smart man he knows how to get you to get
you to watch yeah John what are you
doing I'm pulling can't be up no I don't
take away from the future campus I don't
know he's literally live right now
people wouldn't be able to hear him I've
always wanted to be there the last time
I was there I did tell him like I want
to be there when you have a campy around
like you're so funny you'll be the voice
of reason no I just let him go oh yeah
yeah I'd be like yeah d23 uh physically
assaulted you didn't show me how the
doll Works
took advantage of you did it
oh yeah that's that's what you want is
he actually at the event is he's
screaming from a hotel that makes sense
she's like we gotta like shoot things
and then edit them that's just too time
consuming that's right bro thumbnail lid
and those thumbnails don't even look
that great because I was like I gotta
Rush these up here
anyway you're a failure oh Tim Blake
Nelson Has anyone brought them up in the
Super Chat all right good then we'll
talk about it
Ian Bosch uh was bringing up Tim Blake
Nelson who as you remind him I need you
to all remind in the vehicle is one of
the Stars
I love how that's your that's your
reference for Jim Blake Nelson and he
was also in heavyweights
but yeah we're gonna call people asking
about uh the leader returning and I I
think we said that uh and then a new
Rockstar's reaction recently that it
would be so great to see
um see I'm so tempted you know what guys
we just end the stream and watch campus
I'm so tempted I I've been I've been
wanting Tim Blake Nelson hey it's Tim
Blake Nelson like you got a golden gem
of an actor on your hands you're not
taking advantage of and there was such a
such a great setup for what could become
of him there and for him to be the lead
I mean you have like some familiarity
with the leader from like the Avengers
animated Mightiest Heroes yeah yeah I'm
not too familiar with the character in
the comics but from what we saw in
Earth's Mightiest Heroes and how he was
utilizing that show just how intelligent
he is and whenever he's up against the
Avengers in that show you really feel
like they have no shot against him and
he's always like 20 steps ahead of them
like oh okay The Avengers are gonna be
nope they got no shot against this
against the leader so yeah no I remember
always from that tease I'm like when is
he coming back so I know we got the
actor Tim Blake Nelson and everyone's
favorite comic book film of all time fat
four stick in 2015 where he was chewing
gum so literally in every sheet but yeah
no it's nice to actually see that that
come back to pay off from what happened
where Abomination basically hit him and
then I believe it was Bruce Banner's
blood got into that uh that wound he had
in his head so was it Banner's blood I
forget the detail it was banner I think
his Banner's blood yeah because he was
on the table yeah and he was uh he was
making Blonsky into uh Abominations
Banner's blood that got into his head
right damn that's crazy man
listen
listen um I appreciate you guys are
saying I'm gonna pull up John campy as
live stream on my phone really fast yes
please that's what everyone's been
asking for in the chat
I mean
not even truly lying come on guys I
don't care what opinion you have of John
kampia you know that even if you
vehemently disagree with it can't be
around they're [ __ ] entertaining to
watch I don't care what you say very
true absolutely so entertaining quick
announcement I know this Band-Aid will
not cover the whole wound but to anybody
and everybody who has been reached out
to on telegram or in the comments or on
WhatsApp or anything about a contest
that we're running
please John that is not us if we're
running a contest you will know either
through a video here or the description
or the Community page or on patreon or
some official Channel
we are not contacting you on Telegram
yeah that is not us
no matter how many you ban they they
don't stop
I'm literally commentating
um so look
um
there are people who hit me up about
that and I'm sorry to those who have
been taken advantage of there's only so
much we can do like we have we have
hidden so many of those people like
literally blocked so many of them and
they just keep creating it and it's
happening to like countless YouTube
channels at this point it's just the
current and scam and it's easy on our
end to be like come on people should
know by now but I I completely if I put
myself in like another person's shoes
and maybe not familiar with the
situation I can understand how they can
be manipulated or tricked into something
and please don't give out your
information to anyone and it's because
of them we cannot do any giveaways
that's why we've never done a giveaway
so go to shop.com but if you want to
support patreon or the live stream like
give to us or get a king a citizen Kang
t-shirt we've given some stuff away
actually yeah yeah a little bit a little
bit a little bit
I don't know Camp you shouldn't be upset
about getting the presentation oh come
on Manny ruined Toby McGuire's dick
forever yeah and now he can now he can
like leak whatever he wants
to talk to them about it I want to be
like wait what happened did they invite
you but they wouldn't let you in this
they invited about a spike because
they're like it's gonna be so funny when
we don't let him in
foreign
yeah it's beautiful it's awesome it's so
funny oh I'll text John later he's he's
such a he's fun he's fun he's fun I get
along with campy I mean I like him he's
crazy he is a fun he is a fun
um
Kaden Finch yes please read it thank you
Kaden Finch I know this stream is mainly
Marvel news from d23 but I hope you guys
watch Star Wars tales of the Jedi
trailer if you haven't already think you
will love it especially Greg oh we
watched it don't worry we watched it and
uh you guys are gonna make it you guys
are gonna make fun of me for for what
had happened in that video yeah man when
you definitely see it yeah go um
we'll publish it tomorrow this Enchanted
got lifted
um tales of the Jedi we guess we can put
tomorrow Cobra can we'll just upload so
much but just know guys I am a big Star
Wars fan I do know people's names it's
early in the morning I didn't have my
Jeep I didn't have my G fuel yet to
anybody in the chat concerned as well uh
welcome to a real rejects live stream if
you haven't heard your super chat it's
just in the future we will get there all
right John keep it going it is never
almost never current but it's okay thing
with champion either that definitely
differs is we spend we can sometimes
spend way too long on a certain question
Caden Finch thank you so much for
joining us and for contributing I don't
think you realize if you ever read that
I just read
I'm just making a segment but thank you
again from Kaden Finch to Thomas 562.
thank you 562 Thomas does Eric Voss
smell as good as I imagine him too well
how good do you imagine he smells what's
the bar that you've set he smells pretty
nice where's Creed cologne he smells
like eggs that's a good smell Easter
eggs
even bitter I like that thank you uh
Thomas he's a good smelling guy he's a
mellow dude but he smells uh fresh
Stephen Escalante
thank you for being here do you guys
plan on reacting to tales of the jetty
you should get on that
where is the first thing we we covered
we're like we should just warm up with
this and throw all the little bit tiny
bit out of it and uh
especially watching stumble bee over
here
now that nickname's gonna stick thanks
buddy
that's literally all the names all the
comments yeah yeah I couldn't say Mace
Windu I couldn't say Count Dooku I
couldn't say Qui-Gon Jinn I couldn't say
Ahsoka I was literally fumbling every
now yeah and now all the comments are
gonna be like would you have that guy on
he doesn't know Star Wars dude does it
not matter how much you know Star Wars
you will always be accused of not
knowing Star Wars yeah yeah you're right
I don't know why it's Star Wars I don't
know anything about Star Wars I've never
seen it what is Star Wars
um yeah you see Colin Davidson right he
did sell us on it being insane and it
just wasn't
um it just was it was it was definitely
not an insane one like I don't know what
all my Marvel buddies can really milk
out of this for you know you know it's
all week and a half they'll find a way
yep stumblebee although the secret
Invasion had some good [ __ ] John what
are you doing man nothing
monitoring trying to create an
unnecessary graphic that does not change
the whole vibe of the livestream is
changed the vibe I do love Star Wars for
the most part I'm just downloading it
oh yeah that's right we all thought Joe
she dirty comb will be announced just
update me on what's going on in uh can't
be a stream listen to both of us
give us the play daily updates like like
every couple minutes update me on what's
going on campus
that's the most common Topic in the chat
Ethan
um
thank you Ethan thank you
um for Ramona silence yeah there are
people who who definitely have this book
called my own shout out but it made me
laugh
um Marco done still I think you might
know
Marco ton still what you're talking
about thank you Marco hey shouts out
super sexy Marco he says honestly
I was disappointed
but realized I was expecting too much
and I should be happy what I got secret
Invasion looks awesome though agreed no
it's not your fault don't apologize
what do you mean
they they didn't apologize I know but
but he's taking on the blame of
expecting too much you expected just
enough never apologize I think secret
Invasion does look amazing I mean it
feels like it's got a great
looks like it has a cool pulse to it
it's got that Espionage 70s political
action thriller type like winter soldier
I love that see I feel like Falcon and
Winter Soldiers still tried being you
know like a
pitching something like a cool action
adventure film or or Series right and I
like Falcon and Winter Soldier a lot
more than most people I think I liked
him I liked it quite a bit I feel like
it's just kind of I think because it was
in between One Division and Loki which
are usually hail is the best ones and
um that that it often gets a bad rep but
I think it's a pretty still a really
really solid show and this to me looks
like it could deliver what that that
Flair that people wanted from Falcon and
Winter Soldier but felt like they didn't
get yeah and I think uh I think secret
Invasion might fill that void we've been
looking to for so long
why are you guys complaining we got
traditional new projects that are coming
out soon yeah so maybe we got two
this can't be really trying hard not to
cry God we shouldn't have went live we
just need to we just need to we should
just watch campus we should always
ordered pizza and Swatch campus
that I think jpeg is [ __ ] with Camp
yeah this is
the minute again I was so conv the one
contribution I had on Twitter
was one thing about d23 was on Twitter
when I did say
um with Fantastic Four being announced
tomorrow what do you guys
um like who who was your fan casting I
said something like that who was your
fan casting I really thought we'd get
Fantastic Four I'm not even like
disappointed by the fact we didn't I
just think it's funny I did too and I
think that director whose name I'm
always worried about getting wrong Matt
yes just say that well there isn't
there's a shame there's a shankman in
Hollywood but it's Matt shackman yeah so
I thought um I think he's an amazing
pick for that because I I feel like
with
I feel like what John Watts you would
kind of have an idea of what you'd be
getting I think with
um not very white uh who's who's
the very white one I think we've
released the Barry White cut he hasn't
gained that like we've paid and read to
kind of get an idea with Matt shankman
we've only seen the thing we're most
familiar with him is Wanda Vision which
is a show so we're not exactly sure what
we do but you feel like he he'd be
ballsy enough to do something a little
bit unexpected but still kind of Honor
with the Flair of Fantastic Four is
hopefully you know who they should have
gotten for Fantastic Four Edgar Wright
chance of redemption yeah hold on we're
sorry about Ant-Man Edgar you're
fantastic can anybody verify did Greg
just get called a [ __ ] live on the
campius stream did he call me a [ __ ]
I've been talking great about him he's
crazy
oh no now it's War it's a live stream
war I've been caught I've been praising
campy on this stream he's so fun dude
you're a [ __ ] now once he's branded you
you're a [ __ ] for life he needs to I
think if you really call me a [ __ ]
there'd be a bunch more people coming in
here
probably I think it's so fun he's so fun
I love I love the way the the tone your
voice takes when you talk about it that
way why because he sounds like a he
sounds like
the Sherman Oaks Castle Park or
something he's so fun it's just so fun
to go go play around a mini golf you
know get some pizza play a game
because he's a nice he's kind of like
the billboard
that's a good that's a good such a
strongly opinionated guy in this movie
Spirit that he can be problematic for
some but to me I'm always like it's
funny to me yes it always makes me laugh
I don't feel like he's ever actually
hurt anyone yeah except for ruining
Spiderman you know I think it is funny
all righty thank you Ethan there are
some channels who we are John and I
obviously Humphrey and I obviously make
fun of a lot like without saying who
they are it's like pretty obvious who
we're making fun of
um but I don't I don't love camping into
that I really don't
um
jtvo
dude I didn't know we interactive bad
batch because we just didn't I think you
skipped one yeah what the [ __ ] I thought
we okay so we didn't do I was about to
ask uh if we did Ethan peyote thank you
uh I think secret Invasion will give me
trust issues me too Ethan I don't even
know if these guys are really squirrels
or not I mean I'm having trust issues
too that would be so funny
if uh secret Invasion started getting
the same talk Joker had before it was
released
making people paranoid and not trusting
their friends and family because it's
gonna bring out the worst in us and
we're all gonna devolve into yeah
chaotic dystopia just killing each other
in the streets that's so funny yeah man
can't trust anybody now
they could be a shape-shifting green
aliens yeah
jtvo John uh Andrew Andrew Andrew thank
you jtivo appreciate it Well Done Andrew
yes I'm learning
so a live event for a live audience with
a bunch of exclusive for attendees
wasn't good for the people living in
North Dakota
couldn't have seen that coming it's
almost like it's not for them
that's I mean a fair point I think it
would be much I think any one of us
sitting here would probably be like
pretty hyped if we had just been in the
room for that what I was thinking about
an actual thought that I had a couple
hours ago I want to say it exactly 2 30
P.M uh I thought that I had was maybe
they the the intentional purpose of
being even more adamant about not
letting stuff debut online is
specifically Tethered to wanting to make
sure people make pay the money and make
the effort to get out instead of just
waiting for it to drop online you know
since theaters even though some movies
have done remarkably well for the most
part theaters do have a hard time
and a lot of their films are theater
based despite the fact that they're
primarily pushing their streaming
services and we were talking about that
earlier it could be obviously we think
it was strategically done too with how
they're going to release it as well so
that makes sense yeah true that all
right thank you TiVo
um
what a gem your name's not scribble
oh Michael good you just stay on the
live streams they appreciate you being
here Michael dude thanks brother Yellow
Balloon thank you dude hey we don't
think about like Indy five the reveal a
trailer apparently I don't have the same
type of Conor Forevers HF got choked up
that Harrison Ford it's like the thing
we needed was to get rid of that
spillberg
and we need a new trailer editor
I'll cut the trailer myself
uh and he said it's his last Indiana
Jones movie thank God because he is on
the verge of being you know what I'm
trying to get out of here I don't want
to say it sounds
where was he born 1942 I think correct
1980s pull it up let's pull it up uh
yeah the
the Harrison for just good types
Harrison Ford age would have saved me
yeah it's 80 years old no this is
a Pop's frame come on it's Google yeah
no he should not he should not be doing
more Indiana Jones films
um but I'm a dragon my gut thank you
buddy because the
I was I was watching sometimes I just
binge watch like random celebrity
interviews if I'm in the mood and I
watch so much what I really want to see
is Ryan Gosling and Harrison Ford work
together again oh fun if you guys have
not seen any of the press junkets
Gosling in Indiana Harrison Ford but any
Gosling and Harrison Ford did together
for Blade Runner 2049 I didn't it is the
most fun Harrison Ford is having he's
part of his thing is he always seems
like he doesn't want to be there and
he's kind of an [ __ ] whereas him and
him and Gosling they're like yeah he has
the [ __ ] thing but he's laughing so
much and having such a good time uh and
so that made me go I would love to see
that so I gotta watch that I don't know
I would love to see yeah binge it like
just so every interview they did
together just having such a great time
there was one one funny interview I
think it was with Stephen Weintraub is
that his name Frosty or whatever
collider yeah yeah and he says to uh
Harrison Ford when Force awakens was
command he says uh so uh who shot first
you or Greedo and goes I don't care yeah
that was hysterical
I mean I I think uh I think Indiana
Jones five I'm I am I'm really looking
forward to it I feel like James Mangold
could because the thing with like Steven
Spiel were coming back for Crystal Skull
it felt like he was trying to capture
what he did before and it just wasn't
quite working whereas part five it would
be someone who probably
would want to honor the things he
thought were best about the franchise
but also bring something different to it
and it's James Mangold who to me does
not have a definitive style but has made
such a great variety of different films
like identity 310 Yuma Logan which are
closer than identity
um maybe yeah but he also did uh he did
a comedy that a lot of people didn't
love but I liked it night and day
which is supposed to start Chris Tucker
and Salma Hayek what so yeah I mean
pradonesky
what's up thank you paranesky what's up
it's your favorite super sexy reject
thank you that means you're a patron and
what are your thoughts on d23 because I
thought it was a little really
underwhelming but maybe we've ever hype
going into it
I mean right now yeah I would say more
than I wouldn't say the word
disappointed I'd probably say it was uh
we're sad we're not disappointed we
thought it was squarely well
[Laughter]
I'm like right in the middle of just I
thought there'd be more but hey what are
you gonna do I'm whelmed
whatever is missed was not announced we
will eventually get exactly that's my
whole thought I mean I like the big
crazy hype days don't get me wrong I do
I love that like Comic-Con was insane
like foreign
like that was insane yeah
yeah today was like oh
okay
we caught up we got that secret Invasion
footage that was described to countless
people by this point
that apparently leaked online which
caused it to get blocked for everyone
today
because what happens with these YouTube
systems is like a leaked online
apparently so so whatever person at
Disney had to go in and and go like if
this trailer gets uploaded automatic
block because this is a lead trailer and
so by the time this trailer or the
actual one officially got released they
hadn't let that thing go
from that leaked version so it was
registering that whoever was uploading a
trailer reaction or trailer review today
was stealing the elite trailer and I'm
like so that's what kind of like messed
everything it's happened with Snyder a
cut in the past having with another
there's another movie to happen Deadpool
wasn't Deadpool's a different movie I
can't remember what movie it was but it
happened not long ago
anyway me time
Nolan knable thank you thank you Nolan
thank you thank you just a panel for
fortnite
skins dude
did they announce some fortnite skins or
is it just because they keep collabing
with Marvel over at fortnite dude
fortnite's great fortnite is content
have you ever played fortnite I have not
do I need to get on that oh my god I've
experienced many fortnights
foreign
Batman Arkham Asylum again for the 10
000th time have you got The Last of Us
remastered
uh yes I do oh for PS5 not PS I don't
have a PS5 do you want to buy me one no
okay throw seeds from today's live
stream we'll go to getting Andrew A PS5
I'm trying to raise money for Andrew
although I'm rarely ever home to play
video games that's no excuse no it's no
excuse Andrew dude yeah get me a PS5
I've heard it's absolutely gorgeous and
I want to play it for the replay before
the show comes out when does the show
come out again two weeks from now uh
okay 14. thank you for being here and
for your love and generosity hello and
thank you for your reaction thank you
thank you for thank for being enjoyative
of our reactives I think UK 14. we do
need that Ant-Man trailer uh from Nash
tanadiki singing in the chat eat it I
think we'll get it I think October is
when we're gonna get that trailer I
heard that a while ago and I feel like
that's true and King Kong chaplain
absolutely we must put respect on the
werewolf by Knight's name wow we need it
I love every time where if my knight
comes back around the chat lana.org we
need to go faster we are behind she
super chatted a while ago d23 wasn't
necessary thank you a letdown but it
also didn't come with anything to Hype
me up on what's to come also all three
of you gens are looking handsome and I
love Andrew's mustache that's all thank
you live stream thank you I grew this
mustache just for you Lana so thank you
now um tell wanna how lovely she looks
Lana you look lovely thank you so much I
appreciate it and my mustache I'm gonna
hit on followers we have that's going to
get us canceled I just said Thank you to
be talking about what it looks like that
what is wrong with you
thanks Greg she does have an only fans
though you can pledge to okay will do
we're that's where you can compliment
her okay well sorry about that I will
get on don't didn't mean to him for him
to have this perverted sensibilities
but you should check out her I haven't
been her only fans personally because I
just don't feel like a John can go
you can go
that's what my fiance wants to be
pledging to someone's only fans ah
although I could run a buyer
see what do you think about it
found a list of girls I want to pledge
to an only fans
the gamer and what are you doing John
after an hour into this stream you want
to now make a point nothing is a waste
of Engagement
nothing is wasted there's a lot of
things all right I'm canceling the poll
guys if you didn't get it in
the gamer M thank you Lana that's really
sweet of you go subscribe to her only
thank you for MJ National
treasure to teaser and Percy Jackson
teaser out I'm sure it's amazing
I don't want to watch it right now to be
totally honest with you guys
but is wait is National Treasure with no
it's the show version there will be like
about Nick Cage's dumb kid or something
stupid because they're making a movie
and a show aren't they there's gonna be
another National Treasure movie we gotta
look into this man yeah John is top
priority man this one knows Chris
Columbus working on Percy Jackson I
don't think so man yeah
come on guys the kids no bad talk that's
true no bad talk no bad talk today fans
cannot know about
Lana's
lana.org Lana Del oh my God Lana what's
her fat [ __ ] last name oh my God ah
come on
yeah
don't don't talk about Lana Pico's only
fans page okay we cannot promote don't
don't shower her in my friend's page
don't do it
um
um Abomination is still in She-Hulk Zemo
still hates Heroes Bucky may get Dragged
In from New World Order and thank you
for contributing yes thank you Alvin um
I'm I'm really surprised that I that
would have created so much hype maybe it
kind of ruined something but sometimes
they leave people off the cast list
sure I feel like we want to like
everyone in the world
to um I feel like we want everyone in
the world to
well you could but it might get a little
you can't do it too many characters but
you could do that it'll be in the
they'll be in the lineup down there then
you see Avengers end game everyone was
in that movie I mean I'm excited at the
prospect of Red Guardian and Elena
actually re-teaming again like because
his time will have had to have passed
for them I imagine so seeing where the
relationship has devolved into by that
point and knowing red Guardians still
out there and the school he can come
back because that movie took place in a
specific time frame and now he gets the
chance to come back me and his character
can continue on after
uh and and uh to see yeah yeah sorry
sorry I don't know go ahead Andrew
please what are you excited about The
Thundermans I was just gonna say with
you Elena I love that she was wearing
the in the picture we got the promo
picture that she's wearing the green
vest that uh Natasha wore in Avengers
Infinity War so I thought that was
really sweet
true
I think that's a good calm oh we have we
do have streamlined one lonely stream I
appreciate the people who contribute in
our stream Labs too because
um they take less of a fee than uh
YouTube's like we're taking 80 of what
this person contributed to stream
uh let's see not quite but but yeah John
John can can we see the chat I want to
see the chat again live chat really
quick please
now that we have these mics Andrew we
can actually have a little bit of fun
with the way we do our Audio Oh goody
fun fun is always fun funny like of uh
Die Hard the fourth one where he's like
covering it up and he's like you know
that doesn't actually stop us from
hearing you yeah you're the only one I
know that references is die hard for No
One Live Free or Die Hard no one cares
about die hard I'm gonna give I'm gonna
give an unpopular opinion I'm gonna give
an unpopular opinion I love Live Free or
Die Hard kill me in the comments section
I do like that one can I get a popular
opinion that was fun
um very popular opinion please yeah uh
that X-Men should have been announced
today or some some [ __ ] like some [ __ ]
like that
um okay here we go
where we at George we're going we going
to supers yeah we're gonna be going to
the uh we got one in the Streamline
steam Labs let's do this all right I'm
excited for Cody being in the bad batch
someone you're really championing for
bad batch right now appreciate that
George H oh bronze plays we are going to
end this stream today I'm glad you're
here we're going to end it with reacting
to your short
oh yeah perfect we have it right we have
it saved on the desktop we have it we'll
pull it up we can put it maybe even in
frame well when this stream is ending
and hopefully you guys stick around
we're gonna react to
to uh to a homemade yeah
I'm not a fan George 3025 thank you from
here I'm not a fan of them using the
leader as the main villain and new
Captain Falcon movie Captain Falcon I
wanted to see him facing Hulk that was
the thing I did the center meant that I
did Express to Andrew
um
before
before
um uh hopping on this yeah yeah that I
was like I did want him to fight Hulk
since that was the main setup for it you
know he could still fight yeah I agree I
was I said too when we were talking
about I said either Hulk or even I I
always felt like again from Earth to my
his Heroes he was more of an Avengers
type level villain but again I'm I'm
always curious and open-minded to seeing
how Marvel is going to use him in this
film because you know again he's a
villain more of intellect so to see him
going up against Captain America all
right let's uh Curious well that's
probably what he needs right now because
you know Falcon you know is not
he's Captain American now but he doesn't
have like the super strength of Captain
America you know so this could probably
be the rematch the the kind of the thing
not maybe not Steve Rogers versus red
Red Skull but at least you get a a thing
of
you know you a chance to get a battle
guy with a bunch of wit you know
what I'm saying wait for days all right
John cool let's go over to the soups
because we've got a we gotta wrap a
couple of these up Let me refresh it
I did but oh my God he says Greg check
your Twitter I sent you the F4 lineup
let's see if you're right about any of
this
is it leaked
how crazy would that be if it Fleet
I'm sure they would let it leak we're
not going to announce it today but it's
going to get leaked and we're gonna leak
it ourselves
it could be
it could be leaked
nah it's not possible oh I saw that
picture that's not real at all it's
already in front of a whole crowd of
people that's not real that's not real
my friend don't believe the hype
especially if it's at a whole Auditorium
full of people it's not a real photo
Keys we will watch bullet train when it
comes to streaming I Promise You John
you finally got that graphic up that you
wanted to I know I was working on that
graphic while we were streaming so
it's funny I just needed this I I'd
already made I just needed to save it
and then who's calling you Andrew Nissan
of Van Nuys oh hell yeah dude pay your
car payment nah my leases is almost up
so all righty goddamn shame manager
deuter's Alvin Everett what's up how you
doing thank you for being here we read
it
but thank you again Alvin
cool Jonathan Rubio thank you for being
here thoughts on the leader Scarlet
Witch solo House of M mutants
how will every aspect of the MCU connect
to Kang Street comic Earth Supernatural
Cosmic actually Cosmic
uh Scarlet Witch solo do you want
Scarlet Witch solo film Andrew
uh I mean I'd be down for it I think
Elizabeth Olsen is phenomenal I mean she
really embodies the character she I'm
I'm I'm so emotionally invested in the
character so I mean I'd be down for it
you know as long as the storyline is
epic and uh and the the MCU feels like
or Kevin feige feels like it's a story
worthwhile telling I'm down to see a
solo uh Scarlet Witch film what about
you guys I want to see a Scarlet Witch
guitar solo I'm down for that too
well every aspect of the MCU connected
King
Street Cosmic Earth Supernatural all of
it dude I think that's part of the fun
is Kang is gonna pop up in Places You'll
expect but also places you won't expect
and in iterations you wouldn't have
guessed
you guys are like lawyers with your
answers
okay so I expect it to be mostly Cosmic
maybe a bit Supernatural it will
certainly have effects on Earth one
thing I noticed and learn about John's
you can't tease the guy you know the
Ohio hop to the defenses right away see
Andrew you know how to get teased I've
been getting teased my whole life it's
uh it's a talent
come on John play along yeah everything
everything I can't remember what I was
saying before this so I'll get it I
don't want to tease John it's every it's
upset it's comic
you guys you guys give such safe answers
I love it you're like no I don't want if
Kevin foggy you don't think she's gonna
be a good movie and if it's gonna be
epic and good then yeah I'd like gladly
watch a good Epic movie
answered it so well being serious I mean
at this point with anything the MCU
throws out there I'm gonna at the very
minimum I'm gonna take a look so if they
put out a Scarlet which is awesome I'm
gonna take a look I will it will it will
pique my interest and I love Elizabeth
uh Elizabeth Olsen the youngest Olson uh
sister yeah I think she's a phenomenal
actress she really I the way she emotes
the way she brings the character to life
if they make a solo film I will not
object
it was a lawyer reference I appreciate
it I will I will I will take a look at
it I'm I I'd be curious to see how
they'd do with that if that's what they
want to go
yeah
yeah that's good it's a good answer
there Andrew thank you that was a little
more daring and bold okay it's the same
more broader
Ethan where'd you get the citizen king
shirt
I got it from my brain and working with
the graphic designers at
shopzeroedition.com this is a real
rejects exclusive shirt I love that
shirt and uh yeah you can only buy it at
shopzeroedition.com I appreciate you
asking now Greg knows what's what to get
me for Christmas or Hanukkah I guess in
my case Christmas
from the OC
Dalton duck
John Greg where is your rooster staff
come on guys where is it I don't look
good with a mustache
stash but you got other stuff you know
what I mean if it's just a mustache I
look like a straight up
well I look too good looking and you
guys don't want to be around that
people intimidate us people are
intimidated by how good looking I am
when I when it's just a mustache I'm not
sure I've never done just the stash and
gone out of the house Dolan duck thank
you so much
don't feel like I always need something
else to to balance don't cut your hair
and Dolan you might have just spoiled my
Halloween costume just saying rooster is
that why you've kept the mustache Maybe
just to be rooster you could just be
Maverick
oh yeah so I gotta like actually get
into an F-15 and do a crazy stunt you
have to do any of that and be short uh
and do a running wait did you do a
running sequence in that movie he ran
towards him at one point oh yeah that's
right that's right I literally have Top
Gun clothes you could wear you do
perfect now I don't need to shop oh yeah
you got that badass bomber jacket yeah
it's really hot I hope Halloween's hot
and you have to wear it on Halloween
thanks guys thank you
dead shot thank you Deadshot basically
four Captain Americas for Thunderbolts
what
Bucky
I love Red Guardian I guess Elena and
red guardian or Elaine is a black widow
I guess I get what he's getting at oh
and U.S agent and U.S agent yeah that's
true yeah at least three okay
yeah that's fair I mean
is there any like Supernatural is there
like a like a really fun character on
that team who's on that team exactly I'm
forgetting already who the lineup is
that was announced yeah yeah ghost I
mean ghost oh ghost but what was it
weren't her powers taken away at the end
of Ant-Man the WASP they were restored
yeah they always come back
yeah man for sure dogs again so it was
Ghost and then there was uh Yelena there
was a U.S agent there was a Red Guardian
Elena
yeah uh
uh and then Elaine Valentina
Andrew hold on where is it
you could also go as the gray man I
should do great man I've been hearing
that comment a lot lately there you go
there you go
I will go as The Gray Man there you go
it is a lot of they're they're either
way even if it's not exactly four there
is a high concentration of cap-esque
character I feel like the rooster is the
more popular costume to do this year but
I know gray man was a critically
acclaimed hailed film everyone is going
to be dressing as Miles Teller I tell
you yeah that's a good point I tell you
but does everyone Rock the mustache you
know that's the point that's what makes
it obvious that you're him
exactly
even
Escalante thank you Stephen that's right
Stephen's been [ __ ]
spare patch the stream and another
person too dude bad batch season two
happy Cody is back I'm happy for Cody as
well Cody is shody Commander Cody the
time it's come execute all the 66.
not bad it was okay we need to get Ian
McDermott here it's Commander Cody yeah
they Execute Order
66. you gotta do the face or else it's
not gonna work okay
Greg has been telling me that I gotta do
better with my emoting yeah yeah emote
yeah man you bring your A game of
emoting when you go on jabby coe's
Channel or always shoot like a sketch
everything yeah come here and then you
turn into those rocks and Mario that
drop from the ceiling you know what I'm
talking about
yes Melody you're right Zemo should have
been in Thunderbolts and you know what
Melody I feel like Zemo might actually
be in Thunderbirds hidden surprise I
think Taskmaster has a chance to be
renewed man
Alvin Everett thank you hey Zemo still
hates Heroes plus he's locked up in
wakanda also dual reaction to the Percy
Jackson teaser I've never seen Percy
Jackson or red Percy or no I've read all
of Percy Jackson but I have no interest
in watching this news um I have I've
never seen Percy Jackson and I've never
read Percy have you read Percy Jackson I
have not have you seen Percy Joe I have
not
John Cena
baby maybe we should get drunk first but
yeah let's do it yeah Australian
Palpatine that's not awesome
right dude a crane door I can't remember
who it was off the dome but somebody
just blew my mind with the fact that the
Australian guy in Cobra Kai is the guy
who was Kano I know in the um
I kept on thinking why is that guy look
familiar and then after we saw I was
like damn it
anyway Joshua J Gonzalez no thank you
Alvin it's true Zemo uh of course why
[ __ ] would you not
um
didn't the wakanda's hands emo into the
representative wakanda I believe so yeah
yes yes yes
right yes
yes I believe that's correct
Joshua I did answer your your message
really quick in the middle of doing
stuff sorry but yeah no I believe that
is fake what you sent me but I
appreciate the super chat k14
um I don't have any interest in the
willow thing even though people every
time Man Mod again
sorry it just happens whenever you say
Willow yeah
thank you Zach
I want to watch the woman
um I haven't seen the willow tread now
you grew up on Willow though right yeah
I love that movie I was saying they
should bring Val Kilmer back
I would love to see Val Kilmer back I
don't know if he's physically in shape
to come back to do it but I know we got
him back for spoilers for Top Gun uh
Maverick but I'd love to see him back I
just don't know if he can they should
just deep fake his face onto someone
have his son come back or something and
then you like that I like that
you know it was another good movie
Hawk
because the Matthew Broderick and Renee
Russo
and and uh who's who's the bad guy and
Blade Runner
uh Rutger Howard Rucker Hower you almost
forget what he almost got RoboCop
something Hawk do you guys know what I'm
talking about Matthew brob I think it
was Matthew Broderick and Renee Russo
never heard of that movie Matthew Barber
plays like a beggar
[ __ ] remember
type of Matthew Broderick Hawk
I don't know if I don't know if I'm
getting a ride I never forget the cast
right
lady Hawk that's what it is Michelle
Pfeiffer my bad not Renee Russo Michelle
Pfeiffer
anyway we're moving on same same
difference
um Kingsman thank you lady Hawk Declan
got it thank you thank you Kingsman
Manas maketh okay Caden Finch thank you
thank you I appreciate everyone who
actually to talk for me what is your
guy's theories on Bucky's rolling
Thunderbolts over everything that's
happening so far he's gonna start
killing he's not in it yet that we know
so he's just gonna be like what's the
job I'm gonna have some sarcastic quips
once in a while and he's probably gonna
be
you know what I think Bucky's role is
actually going to be on a very sincere
note okay that is a Zemo
yeah that was it's easy to get those
names mistaken yeah they have all the
same letters yes exactly
thank God
I think Bucky's role in Thunderbolts
will probably be how
he a lot of these people
I don't know about a lot of them but
some of them are defined as bad people
you know and Bucky has been kind of the
worst of them all right except for
Taskmaster
but the human taskbaster probably have a
lot in common from being mind controlled
and to kill people
um they're all gray but I think Bucky
has shown such a an elevated growth of
he is not a bad guy anymore
and he has found a way to be good and he
could probably hit perhaps inspire
people emotionally or bring out the good
in them maybe he's there yeah to to be
the good influence on the rest of the
team and have to like guide them yeah
yeah because the other one has been some
like maybe none of them have really
cared about repenting I thought he was
just going to be there to cry that he
didn't get the Captain America mantle
that's what I thought he was in there
yeah
180 from Falcon in the Winter Soldier
and just be like I deserve that Shield
but what's who's directing Thunderbolts
did they announce that yeah yeah a while
ago
oh that's right dang hold on but I think
whoever the director is is gonna start
sleeping with Sebastian Stan and it's
going to create a lot of tensions on set
as the Director is distracted and not
able to direct Florence Pew Jake
schreier this should get Olivia Wilder
director that would be great director of
Paper Towns and the Robot and Frank Jake
schreier is directing this move if you
guys seen the video of Olivia Wilde
being asked directly about that
situation at a press conference and how
she does not directly answer the
question in which situation about about
all the drama and like foreign
it's a long answer that doesn't answer
the question which deflecting answer is
it
lately great answer
it sells the Bloodstone is in werewolf
by a knight Joshua yeah sure is great
Ethan Pia Miguel this is still soon
sure ish soon in the next 10 to 20 years
flew over my head but apparently that
reference in
um I'm about to ruined she hook up so
far for you oh no oh the the ramp
there's a character in there named
Madison super ugly girl it's just like
so so no not attractive and not likable
people they blurred her face out they
had to blur out because of how ugly she
is and how it caused a series she is
people were just bitching about how
terrible she is on Twitter so I know you
haven't seen it yet but that's the
reality of what it went down that's
what's yeah and don't look on Twitter
don't look on Twitter if you don't want
that to be a firm for you so
that's really Mephisto I know that she
encountered that she encountered
Mephisto she doesn't say Mephisto but if
you line it up
it's like that's probably Mephisto
okay I will connect the dots when I
watch it the fist bro he's coming
and also was a great point if they
announced Abomination it might have
spoiled the ending of She-Hulk dude
truly
true this and true that Bucky Barnes my
friend the why isn't where you think
that's a reference to Madison but I was
just saying that everyone thought was
really ugly and no one liked it all yeah
now I understand that bro yeah yeah the
why is where why would you put her in
this show no one had a positive opinion
about her she people hated her the
crypto boy what the hell happened with
John thank you the crypto Boy by the way
thank you thank you remember thank you
crypto what the hell happened with John
Candy at d23 he's dead now well he went
to d23 and they were like why aren't you
the Spider-Man Toby McGuire Digga
hi
Toby Maguire today you can't you can't
walk in here right now
everyone's gonna be like what Tom
where's Dick guy get it walking here
this is not right man so um yeah they
had to boot him out now he's mad at
Marvel and he wants to take the
joke he wants to choke out like he's
gonna you're gonna have a celebrity
death hatch I actually have no idea what
happened dude I think they should arm
wrestle
I think Shield is becoming Canon and she
I mean Shield is Canon
question's probably is Agents of Shield
oh yeah multiversely speaking probably
well Chloe Chloe is rumored to possibly
come back huh your favorite characters
Clark um I like wake
I don't know if she's my absolute fave
but I like Quake okay I'm coming in here
and correcting me with
this I like uh Chloe Bennett then
you know I gotta hang out with the
creators of agency I know that's cool
Marissa super nice you mean Sequoia on
the show
she's a cast member she has a small role
in a few episodes yeah and then and then
when they credited her I was like that's
the person whose name I keep seeing is
like co-executive producer showrunner
dang bye Alex uh yeah no I uh she's such
a sweetheart and such a great energy and
uh oh I've never seen her work oh yeah
yeah
she's uh she's a fun character give her
my compliments yeah I'm curious if I'm
really close character too uh Alan
McIntosh so much hype for such an
unfortunate sadness
is such a heartbreaking event people
will think back and remember let's have
a moment of silence every year on
September 10th it's like when we watched
black panther wakanda forever trailer
it's that type of sadness I felt when I
I think of d23 yeah step no I'm not
gonna say that joke they gotta what they
it's mid Arnold's right it was mid you
know mid mid is the new adjective some
people are like defending the [ __ ] out
of it and other people are hating it and
I'm like right in the middle it's a
middle middle or if anything Star Wars
kind of delivered more
yeah well now because I feel like
they've set the bar Lower for themselves
with all these things that they've put
out well there was just one d23 that was
just [ __ ] insane remember that 1d23
yeah when it was like here's your
wonderful
trailer
here's what's coming down here's what's
coming out hers is coming down and then
Star Wars was like we got [ __ ] hidden
Christians
[Laughter]
oh d23 t-shirts on the back to say [ __ ]
Comics it was so insane that they're
like you think you're kind of walking
into something absolutely gonna be half
bad and it wasn't even half that you
know
but that was also too after we had just
come that was in the first year of the
pandemic right so I believe so yeah yeah
so it makes sense that they had to like
hey we want to show up everything
because we have not really released
anything this year yeah yeah because
it's right they had like a year without
marble and they made up with it by
giving us like 12 projects a year
um it's like we didn't make up for lost
time then our kids were being neglected
uh take your time Marco Tunstall how
excited are you guys for werewolf by
night I'm so excited uh thank you Marco
by the way thank you it's really easy to
take for granted when people Super Chat
and so thank you
for me I just I'm like hmm
you should be quadrupling with your
super here
or else should I even read it um it
looks like nothing the MC has ever done
before I thought of John especially
right after I finished watching I agree
Mark Oh I thought of John too I thought
of myself I just thought of me I I
thought of John as well after watching
it I was like John's probably really
liking this but I don't want him to have
that so I'm gonna I don't I'm gonna
pretend you're not gonna turn into a
werewolf on a full moon are you John I'm
gonna make this my thing instead I yeah
I don't know have you ever seen me on a
full moon
I don't think I have this worries me now
say tough to say who knows I really love
the style I mean a lot of people might
not notice about me but I'm really uh
not to just take away John's Thunder
it's fine and you know what I won't uh
John why don't you take it away
I loved I you know what to me honest
honest answer is uh to me that was the
most exciting thing but partly because
like that kind of tonal surprise uh is
more fun and exciting than like a
casting announcement to me so it's like
oh dang this is like a language I never
expected from you guys and if you know
it holds if that's a very authentic and
kind of all-encompassing trailer then
like oh cool like we're really gonna
spend a little time in a different
stylistic Lane that can enhance both you
know the harder core elements that
they've gone been going for lately and
the humor everybody finds so contentious
um so I yeah I was totally dazzled
because yeah it goes after a whole bunch
of stuff that I love but also marks a
new thing I haven't seen from the MCU
yet yeah right and like a couple new
things because you know there are horror
properties on the horizon and we've had
dips into horror with certain things
especially Multiverse Madness and Moon
Knight and things like that but uh yeah
this was the most like oh no no yeah
we're doing like classic a blend of
classic horror like this looks like
partly it looks like every trailer from
Grindhouse mashed into one yeah true uh
basically but uh yeah I I was I'm I'm
still giddy it's how it's what Teen Wolf
should have been
Kevin we love Teen Wolf great movie
foreign
yeah sorry Johnny we're talking
I don't think I've never talked
have I talked I don't think I've been
talking what whenever when have I ever
talked
yes yes no I think I think it is uh
you want me to get this one yeah
Cosmic reader thank you Cosmic reader we
really appreciate your comment
felt like the video you guys made about
how we shouldn't get over hyped should
have been saved for d23 and San Diego
Comic-Con I know right you know what you
should do is you should just you should
just repost that video each time and
just like replace a couple just the name
of the convention and put up a different
thumbnail yeah every convention
yeah man uh
I should have uh yeah I done [ __ ] up
man
who the [ __ ] up I should have should
have told you all to lower your
expectations this week
you did please see if you tell someone
to lower your expectations and then it
ends up delivering then I've still done
a service yeah because you made it that
much because now it's better because
your expectations were lowered now it's
mind-blowing and then if you lower your
expectations and then it doesn't
actually deliver then it's like okay
well at least I prepared myself to love
her so it never hurts to lower your
expectations no because that
disappointment you can't ever be
disappointed exactly exactly done
Spider-Man 2 yep Spiderman Spider Guy
might have been Spider-Man three oh
that's a good one Kingsman Kingsman
thinking Kingsman
do you think there's a scroll hiding in
the Avengers team for sure and waiting
for the right moment to show impossible
there's Tony Stark who put a suit of
armor Tony didn't really die and put a
scrub of armor
dude I knew Tony didn't really die it
was all a ruse
uh nah no I think they're pissed off the
world if that
unless it was like someone you don't
give a [ __ ] about it was Black Widow and
she's not really dead this girl's
kidnapped her yeah right Widow died for
the Soul Stone it was Captain America
unless it was like uh you know
um
Hawkeye or something
oh poor Clint that is one damage scroll
in the Hawkeye series I don't know you
know he's really he's really become this
guy this guy's life is so hard
um yeah no I don't I don't think anyone
is is actually
um yeah doing that dude
they could explain some of the Roadie
stuff with scrawlness sure man
hey we should uh
okay
hello oh it's on oh you don't even know
I did it that's what happened you didn't
you didn't say anything how crazy would
that be Joseph if Deadpool did make an
appearance in She-Hulk dude Hulk pool
and they don't even talk to each other
they're just both talking to the cat
it's like when John and I sometimes are
talking to you guys but we're talking to
ourselves
I mean yeah Andrew do you want to get
out of here all right I'll see you guys
you can leave Andrew
do you want me to leave Craig what about
you guys do you guys put a new poll up
there yes should Andrew leave I have a
feeling it's gonna be yeah it's gonna be
a wow 100 yes
don't put that up
don't don't encourage people to say
positive things about Andrew either
because then if they don't that's mean
no you're setting him up for disaster I
told him not to do it okay all right I'm
not doing it
I told him not to do it I'm not doing it
Andrew can't take a joke he's like you
oh no Andrew I'll teach you how
I'm staying one lesson ahead buddy I I
I've been the brunt of jokes for the
last 34 years of my life no you haven't
have you yeah
no I'm sorry it's okay we'll get ready
for another 34. as long as we're friends
it's gonna be good
I'm Tom Clancy I like a good night all
right guys we're turning off the Super
Chat so he's turned off gotta prep
thumbnails for stuff tomorrow
including but not limited to COBRA Kai
episode 2. because Cobra Kai always
sounds like it's going to be massive and
then ends up being just all right
well this time we actually like we did
our reactions and our reviews for but
perfect timing for when it came it was
released terrible time for it to come
out
and it's gotten lost in the weeds
unfortunately
uh median nights do you guys think we'll
get thank you meeting tonight thank you
thank you thank you Andrew thank you
Greg do you guys think we'll get a
midnight Suns project announcement
anytime soon no no no if they're holding
out on all this [ __ ]
seriously that's if that happens that's
gonna be a long ways away well I got
this citizen king shirt from
shopzeroedition.com
Greg just came up with it himself oh yes
he did and then I said you guys bring my
vision to life and design
do it draw for me
um anyway maybe after blade because you
guys are freaking hilarious on the
stream thank you uh I don't think we'll
get a midnight Sun's project announcer
anytime soon eventually one day but not
anytime soon I think I think feige and
Company have been like
you know what we need to slow down our
audience a little bit they should be
entitled to the beginning way too ahead
of themselves
we need to start lowering their
expectations because oh are you leaving
Bucky I mean Joe oh man no man I like
you when you're here oh I think Bucky
Barnes HDL is not happy when I'm here
sorry Bucky it might have something to
do with you Andrew it's your fault and
this is why you have to take over the
channel
uh yeah no I mean
there might be something so massive
happening but I'm like that's what
surprises me about that's what surprises
me is like they they've revealed like
where where I feel like maybe within
their mind they're like you know we
already told them it's gonna be secret
Wars in Kang Dynasty how much bigger is
it gonna get yeah what else do we need
to reveal anytime soon dude you're
revealing other [ __ ] right now like
that's massive that's that's the ironic
part to me is like Secret Wars in King
Dynasty if you want more it's so big
yeah it is so big it's so big when it's
all rolled up and and now they're just
trying to get us to pay attention to the
the nearest things that are coming out
right like keep your attention there
instead of just waiting for Secret Wars
in King Dynasty
and yet we're still here like
it's kind of disappointing didn't give
us more it wasn't enough I didn't hear
about who's playing Mr Fantastic and I
didn't get my X-Men announcement with
Miss Marvel although it is a little odd
that they would they would team they
would even hear about it right you
didn't watch it um they would tease you
know the mutation thing in Miss Marvel
you spoiled it for me Greg well you know
what you're racist for not watching yeah
and sexist too I can add that as well
because she's a woman there's so much
hate in your heart sexist and racist and
they're probably homophobic yeah that's
why you have me on that you told me
I know we need to balance it placate to
a certain crowd exactly uh
you haven't called us soy boys once
or at least a cuck or something whatever
leads to monetization is the game yeah
whatever leads to engagement and Views
don't worry guys off camera I called in
that all the time but the uh thanks the
uh
I'm sorry what were we just talking
we're talking about hype we didn't get
our Fantastic Four announcement oh yeah
yeah but it's like we should I think um
I think yeah we got people got ahead of
themselves but come on you can't fault
anyone it might be a tad more yeah at
least release publicly online
although what we did get was awesome I
do agree with you though I mean I can
understand everyone's disappointment a
little bit towards the Fantastic Four I
mean with all what we've gotten so far
from the Fantastic Four on screen so I
can understand everyone's type hey we
finally got the Fantastic Four in the
MCU like this film has been announced
for a long time we had John Watts now we
don't now we have a new director like at
least let's get our cast I mean the best
iteration of Fantastic Four that we've
ever gotten so far is The Incredibles so
I can understand everyone's you know
premonition day we just want to know at
least who the cast is you have to give
us like a trailer or anything so I I can
understand the disappointment with that
or at least the set right now I get it I
get it man dude Andrew doesn't need to
explain to yourself really quick there's
an important question in the chat what
does it say rip man's land wants to know
if you work out Andrew works out damn
Greg he does work out in fact I saw him
at the gym earlier this is my secret War
right here dude you should do a workout
live streaming and get this though every
Super Chat is what exercises the real
workout that would be exhausting that
would be crazy I've been streaming for
four hours meaning I've been working out
everywhere
think of it everybody comments and what
type of exercise and the amount is how
many reps
yeah Greg does Super soon it makes so
much out of out of like uh spite alone
but John doesn't need to work out to
keep the attraction that's a great thing
I need to work out I'm not in good shape
Andrew flecks
dude come on come on dude show it off
you know you've got it to flaunt it show
us your body show us you want to be a
star don't you Andrew
make with the muscle
it's all about nutrition guys it's all
about the Caps cancel my three o'clock
the media nights we read that John I
know I'm just transitioning pickle
Brickle pickle pickle brick an awesome
name thank you thank you for the moment
of silentio Alvin Everett we need to
learn from One Division stop Opera
hyping things expect disappointment and
you'll never be disappointed dude I feel
like I've heard that before yeah man
freaking uh Emma Stone Amazing
Spider-Man Emma Stone and Birdman
definitely mm-hmm
I was still you will never learn from
Wanda you know why we don't learn from
One Division because some people were
like
Spider-Man no way home ain't gonna be as
good as you think it is and there's not
going to be as many people as you think
there is and then there was
yeah so it's like you thought maybe
Spider-Man no way home would have taught
us like one division would have taught
us but then you got somebody Spider-Man
home which like oh my God they they even
went further I thought they'd be like
five minutes in that movie
they were in there for a while they were
real characters
so they really were I was gratifying
that was like a great film surprised
that's a great film No Way Out
I love no way home that's just like a
genuinely like it's a great movie
nothing has been no way home nothing
I mean it is a unique experience
um truly what was it but was it as good
as June 1984 dude nothing's better than
due 1984. nothing in this life also
inside inside joke guys oh somebody just
removed the Andrew comment I was gonna
highlight someone thinks you look like
Chris Evans and also they're calling you
out for that rooster beach scene oh
thanks Nora did the muscle thing oh yeah
thank you thank you guys yeah you know
what really helps this dream Labs is
every time you mention it then people
actually go really yeah yeah so that's
nice so every five minutes like a radio
station we'll just mention it
Alan Smithy thank you I love your films
thank you
hey real Rejects
uh
I used to drink crappy movies I now work
as a film or archivist
if we got our own d23 paddle 525 to 6
1500 years of Hollywood magic a Disney
tour of the UCL UCLA film and television
archive Hyperion stage Cambio will love
it Alan Smithy I hope John campia
attends and then talks about
disappointed
I thought there'd be more at the 100
Years of Hollywood Magic
there were only maybe 60 years at most
what do you think about this Rob oh yeah
John I I agree they're only 60 years at
most but I thought it was pretty good
is this real that sounds like a really
cool pin it sounds great actually I have
to see this battle you know I've never
seen you guys imitate me
you don't want to imitate me do you not
in front of you I do you have to shaved
him check it out like oh I'm I'm friends
with Greg but now I'm gonna I go on his
brother's Channel a lot now I'm Andrew
and I love you and more now chabby Quay
he appreciates me BBS right guys oh he
appreciate it anymore oh yeah yeah don't
forget who gave you your start here on
YouTube don't you [ __ ] forget that
get on your knees Andrew I gotta gut you
on camera it's true guys he did he
actually did eat the octopus Andrew get
who invited you discovered you at a
party son of a [ __ ] pool party guys you
want to be a star don't you kid
there's no loyalty get out of those
trunks I got this one popcorn thank you
popcorn for the comment we appreciate it
hey y'all hey non d23 related question
if that's all right of course it is
that's cool Greg
were you always a big crier your Green
Mile reaction made me subscribe and I
just love that you're not afraid to sob
I will answer this question not Greg we
don't need his opinion
guys Greg has sat through a lot of
movies with me
and I'm a talker as you can tell
and sometimes when I talk I will Express
what's about to happen in a film or make
a prediction and then Greg just starts
sobbing like why am I sitting next
so he's always been a big Greg started
sobbing because you're a talker and I'm
a breather and between it was sitting
between the two of us most egonious
things in between the two of them like
agonizing well you see John's like the
heavy consistent breather
I'm not the first one to say it don't
get all [ __ ] defensive I've accepted
it and now it's just a part of my
viewing experience is focusing problems
I'm too anal
laughs
and Andrew is a different kind of
breather he's like A build-up breather
yeah
he
goes
starts he starts small
and eventually just like every like I
sometimes I time it every like two
minutes you set your watch he just goes
here's your invitation to me finally
nailed it so good and you sit between
those two and then I'll hear it yeah
where's John's loud breathing is like
she's opening your mouth a tiny bit John
I do now I see every movie now is like a
meditation experience because I'm
focused on each breath a little clog
there and where it's coming from Mindful
breathing yeah it's a mindfulness
exercise I don't get much of the plot
but I am very Serene at the end of it
and Andrew's like this is like build up
breather like gearing up to like kick a
ball um I gotta store up this breath for
the winter I'm gonna answer your
question uh no I mean I I think I think
it's just what's I think the main
difference for me is like what has made
me cry is the thing that that affects me
differently like what gets me riled up
is
something loving or something that is I
feel like something wrong is happening
it's not like some type of Injustice is
happening to someone that that's the
thing that really gets me crying
and um I think about soccer mom I was
like it's not right I think that's what
I was saying and everybody was like it's
not right man it's not right it's not
right
it's not cool man every time I've
watched that film I've definitely weeped
too and fun fact about that movie do you
guys know who the first choice for that
role was I told you Leo DiCaprio exactly
as John cuff
Shaquille O'Neal boy I'm so glad they
went with Michael Clark Duncan only for
sure was it a stature thing I don't know
why would it be it was for acting like
um but I'm glad they went with Michael
Clark Duncan because he was amazing oh
but uh recipes I learned a few years ago
that crying is um I feel like people get
afraid to show that and I and I kind of
made it an active thing to not be afraid
to show it
and it's healthier than taking a lot of
medications it's actually really good
for you if you if you do cry I mean you
can be like overly sensitive there's no
wrong you can be overly since and then
and I've I've had my times where I could
be overly sensitive I think that reaches
people in the most potent way too uh
just like if you're like really moved to
tears on on camera or something more so
than a laugh even or like a big you know
like yeah I feel like that really gets
people kind of vulnerable with you I am
grudo too thank you hopefully with this
Multiverse Saga coming we will get to
see how kings Multiverse Madness
affects our heroes and more movies it is
so and let's see Captain Hydra I really
like to come to his channel and also
hear you guys talk about the the ma is
there oh do we need to refresh I don't I
don't know let's do it let's refresh it
just in case talk about no no talk about
the Marvel or the Multiverse or
something like that the MCU
uh yeah I do think that Captain Hydra
especially would be something that'd be
really cool to actually see I don't I
mean if Chris Evans was game to do it
that would be the best like how exciting
how much more exciting would that be oh
dude than like some guy playing Steve
Rogers and doing Captain Hydra like yeah
if Chris Evans came back someone will do
something like that I hope it's him he
said he's not opposed to returning in
something yeah I saw that
he should have come back as falcon
well no there is Falcon
immediate now they got to get Robert
Downey Jr for that that would be cool
oh
yeah it's an alternate timeline where
Minstrel shows became the norm of all
Society ugh it's really quick though
Johansson
Scarlett Johansson's John Coffey says
the chat also
leave She-Hulk twerking alone it's fine
were people mad about that no well
people are mad about that on the
internet but then I saw what a gem said
she hoped working isn't loving real
tearjerker right there and it is a
tearjerker I feel like uh it's an
asterisk I didn't get some people were
upset by it I know I don't get it but uh
it's within the realm I was turned on so
I was fine
it was it was for my sexual
gratification so you were upset that you
had blue balls it was after I pleasured
myself to the thought of Shield twerking
that I was mad once the shame returned
to my body
I thought about how the Lord would Smite
and then I blame She-Hulk for what I did
yeah because it is her fault for
attempting you the cycle of American men
continues yes the strong and proud
tradition
yes it's life a little dude we're done
right
sometimes people send little stickers at
the end but yeah I think we're not good
not today John yeah not today but not
today don't worry about it so it is not
this day not not today not today mate
well let's hang with the chat for a
little more longer gotta work on some
thumbs guys reckon crew is a joke
damn
uh yeah see that's the thing yeah people
say Marvel's pushing the agenda but
there are lots of socio-political issues
in the comics it's a good point not
enough John it's not enough
I think there could be more people
people not happy with the Wrecking Crew
though The Wrecking Crew and a little
live but then Russian crew gets their
asses beat all the time in the comics
yeah and they'll be back that kind of
[ __ ] man they'll be back and they'll
always level up and they'll always get
thwarted
and uh yeah Greg does Love The Little
Mermaid and I do too so what
John don't try to take my moment away
from me I wouldn't that movie is for you
you're the target democratic I love that
trailer it is a good trailer I I would I
I think she's going to be phenomenal
Halle Berry Bailey I'm sure
she's been called Halle Berry for real
many times
someone said Andrew's so handsome a lot
of people think you're very handsome man
because I have such handsome friends oh
no you would be uglier by comparison if
that were the truth true yeah it's like
we wouldn't up value if there's a group
of three good-looking guys naturally you
go who do I think is the best looking
one
and
I know I'm the one constantly winning
this argument you are the two of you
guys
are always like it's Greg for sure I
mean you've got the nipple chills how
can I not pick up the most active chills
man I don't get a lot of nipple response
it's a lot of things we do
um
but no a lot of people are always saying
that about you man thank you I
appreciate it appreciate everyone how do
you do it
uh genetics I don't know I need to I
stay so handsome man
yoga Pilates it's like calisthenics been
away a little while I've been taking the
Harry's exfoliant wash lately
and uh take G fuel a little bit of
eucalyptus inspired I'm gonna have to
try that it sounds good Elite Marriott
gets it yeah right Greg and John have a
sexy logic that's always a plus that's
what I do fresh says I hope the series
ends with She-Hulk making the stallion
and the leader oh man
I would love to see Megan the stallion
and the leader Twerk it off together
yeah who would make a better Wolverine
Mike Myers Adam Sandler Mike Myers Mike
Myers I think I could answer that
honestly but he's got to look like The
Love Guru actually Adam Sandler could do
that rage though and the sarcasm yeah
from Happy Gilmore that rage yeah
that's what I would think of have you
seen like
um uh uncut gems
no I only saw the first 20 minutes was
on Christmas day of the year it came out
but I I it was Christmas day it was
Christmas Day
I actually did come here once on
Christmas remember for Deadpool oh yeah
I remember I was at the restaurant Greg
I got a text hey man no it's Christmas
but can you come over and do a reaction
with me I was like today you're like
yeah you're Jewish
yeah step off that's like me slumbering
Chinese New Year
in Japan
I have to try that one eating Italian
food you know what I'm saying I'm gonna
have to try that one day but he's oh
dude freaking uh not Rob Williams Adam
Sandler is uh amazing in that movie yeah
I I've heard no I'll see it someday we
haven't seen it I don't see him yeah
I had a headache and I was on edge and I
had so much I just did not feel good and
I couldn't stop watching that's
literally destroyed by that film that is
literally everything I've heard about
him is like it is the most tense
unsettling like stress induces yeah it
is so stressful and I'm just gonna spend
the movie like that's where John can get
all his screaming John will scream so
much during it that he will never do his
I'll never signatures
cringe faces again yeah so chill nothing
has ever been more cringy than this and
now it'll never it'll be like a full-on
massage for my emotional Spectrum you
know when I know anything about it about
the ending or the beginning or the
middle or the first balls I know is the
vague idea that Adam Sandler is like he
needs to pay something off for some he's
in some kind of bookie trouble and it
needs to go from place to place to place
and it's like a you know Katamari of
circumstances trying to solve it and it
just keeps getting worse I feel he
should have been nominated well he
wasn't even nominated for that nope the
Sandman was not he was not even
nominated I thought he was just like oh
my God what yeah because didn't he
threaten to make a bunch more shitty
movies if he wasn't nominated he's so
good in that movie he won like the
Screen Actors Guild award for that yeah
he he did win Awards but yeah he was
another knit of the DS I would love to
see Adam Sandler in the MCU walking
around in his long shirt and baseball
and basketball shorts
baseball caps
is there I am inevitable is there any is
there any MCU films you all hate with a
passion
MCU films that I hate with a passion
out of them that Inspire hatred to me
yeah I'd say my least the one I like the
least is probably and I don't dislike
the film like to the point of hatred but
probably Thor uh the Dark World no I
didn't see it coming I actually remember
being kind of and I just did that
reference
Mickey
sorry Greg what were you saying I
remember being a bit of an odd duck and
being like you know what I like kind of
like Thor the Dark World it's not that I
saw some of it on TV again recently I
was like
it's terrible it's just not especially
great but there are moments there are
good things in it the thing that's that
if you're gonna call it saving the film
I love all the interactions between Loki
and Thor that's what saves that film for
me but malekith was such a letdown for
me
uh Black Widow is pretty frustrating for
me oh yeah I'd put Black Widow up there
too I wouldn't say I hated it but it was
it got pretty frustrating I think
nothing was more frustrating than
Jessica Jones season two
that was really rough was that the one
with her mother or yes okay
it took me a long time to get through
season two
it was really we actually started
watching our patreon and they were like
five episodes there like guys we just
can't tease this is not getting better
this is too hard like I cannot continue
this I would actually say yeah Jessica
Jones season two is the hardest one yeah
and I love season one season one still
comes to my mind and uh and season
season three is still good to me it was
fine I'm teeny Rand I think people put
more tired people put that Iron Fist so
much that I I couldn't help but like
take some amusement from it even though
it is kind of boring it's not
disappointing the same way because it
never had a greatness to live up to like
Jessica Jones's first season well and it
was like this weird magical show but
that just had no magic or in its Spirit
it was such a bizarre show it was it was
bizarre
um like Iron Fist yeah I know wasn't the
best but I I enjoyed Iron Fist season
too I enjoyed iron for season I love the
ending too to the Iron Fist season two
was like hey got me I need to see more
than we never got to see more and I
didn't uh but iron for season one was uh
I guess two with Jessica Jones it was
like so great the first season and the
second season was like oh my God I am
hating this what happened and and uh and
then Iron Fist though was at least like
Jessica it was like at times at least it
was like laughably bad
who's bad yeah I remember photographers
was asked for sure so it led to Greg and
I saying this literally a million times
the for like three months to each other
that's literally
Greg and I didn't have any conversations
we just said that that would consist of
our conversations only a lot of people
were saying they spied Misty Knight in
one in uh secret invasions trailer today
which that would I mean Luke caves
universe but that I was saying you know
shared Netflix universally that'd be
cool tonight back again bring Misty
Knight back oh my God yeah she was great
she was awesome she was hot she was
amazingly hot that sure said hot woman
she was very very much a woman Kristen
Ritter Christian Ritter the other one
they didn't they haven't confirmed this
hers
what's her homie's name Trish or is it
not Trish what's her Trish becomes
unbearable yeah and season three she
becomes
the apps have you seen Jessica Jones
season three I have not seen season
three she becomes absolutely unbearable
just don't like Australians is that it
blonde women
her birthday is July 11. I want to cut
their head their scalp alive my dreams
to emerge from the outer back with a
fistful of Aussie scalps
uh yes we turned the super chats off you
can send stickers if you would like no
no we should end this stream uh guys
thank you for being here today
um you didn't miss us talking about Echo
task force we didn't really talk this
was fun Andrew why I'm just gonna leave
man they're just like suck around for a
couple hours and they were like yeah you
know live stream now Colleen Wing I
appreciate that of course all right
all right guys look we gotta end but
thank you for being here thank you guys
thank you guys gotta work on a couple of
other thumbnails and then I'm gonna try
to get some sleep because d23 was
disappointing and they didn't give us
enough content to cover today
they owe us and we're keeping a tab
Kevin
[ __ ] mother feige [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right guys we'll see you all soon
thank you for being here much love peace
be with you all
oh we didn't watch the no we can't end
yet